Speaker 1: . Hey, David, is the Republican
20, 20, 22 strategy going to be merely Trump?
So a lot of people are writing to me with
versions of this question, which is what are
Republicans going to run on in twenty, twenty
two in the midterms where everybody in the
House is up for election and a third of the
Senate is up for reelection, what are they
going to run on?
Because there's no policy that they're advocating
for now.
It's just oppose the Democrats, obstruct the
Democrats, as Noam Chomsky told us earlier
this week, blow up anything you can that Democrats
are going to try to do.
It's not really policy, and that's absolutely
right.
I believe that there is no interest from the
Republican Party in actually going back to
policy for twenty, twenty two.
And as a result, the Republican Party is taking
a risk that they can make the case that things
are really bad under Joe Biden and things
have been bad.
So what is it going to be that determines
what happens in twenty, twenty two?
It's going to be how is the economy doing?
Have we recovered from the virus?
And remember that we are just six or seven
months now from twenty twenty two.
These races are going to start ramping up
in January, February, etc..
What is the economy look like at the time?
If the economy is not so good and Republicans
can blame Biden, then they have a shot at
doing well in the House and maybe in the Senate
as well.
If there's a resurgence of the virus and Joe
Biden can't get it under control, that's going
to play against Democrats in twenty, twenty
two.
But when they remove themselves from any serious
policy discussion and become the party of
no, no, no, that package is too big.
This package is too big.
We can't afford it.
Biden's bad.
Don't let Biden do infrastructure.
Don't don't get vaccinated.
Don't do all this different stuff.
You are taking a very big political risk that
you will be able to say, I told you so as
you get to twenty twenty two and say you need
to put us in in order to fix this.
Now, Donald Trump is going to come in from
the top in all likelihood and start saying
these are the good Republicans that you should
support.
These are the bad Republicans who don't want
to support these people.
And what influence he has will also determine
what things look like if Trump has lost influence
and the economy's doing well.
And Trump says reelect Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Lauren Bobert and they lose.
That bodes very poorly for Donald Trump and
the Trump wing.
For twenty twenty four.
The economy's not so good.
There's a resurgence of the virus.
If inflation were to get out of control, which
I don't think will happen or whatever, and
Donald Trump can come in and say, see, you
need me back.
And for now, here's the 50 people I'm supporting
and a bunch of them when it reinforces Trump
and Republicanism and it probably pushes Trump
to look at running in a serious way in twenty,
twenty four.
So in twenty, twenty two you will also be
up against.
I mean, listen, even if Trump remains popular
in November of twenty, twenty two and gets
behind a bunch of candidates, they're not
going to be as interesting to many of these
Trump voters as Trump was himself.
So there are lots of these what we might call
low propensity Trump voters who were not engaged
in politics before 2016, who did get out and
vote for Trump.
And while they were there, they checked off
whatever Trump in Republican was running on
their ballot as well.
A lot of them are going to stay home in twenty,
twenty two unless an urgent case for look
at how terrible everything is.
We've got to get AOC out.
We've got to get Pelosi out, you know, get
them all out sort of thing.
A lot of them are going to stay home and turnout
isn't going to be great.
Then the question is, do these college educated
and suburban, these groups that have been
shifting more and more towards Democrats,
do they also stay home as there's generally
lower turnout in midterms?
Or do these key growing groups for Democrats
get out and vote if the Democratic emerging
electorate votes?
And the Trump people don't because they're
bored with politics, it's probably fine for
Democrats in twenty twenty two.
If the economy's bad and Trump weaponized,
is it with disinformation and weaponized propaganda
and his voters get out?
It could be very bad for Democrats.
How does Biden do is question one?
We don't know the answer yet, but seven, eight
months from now, we're going to be in the
heat of it.
So plenty of time to discuss.
Don't miss today's bonus show.
It's a good one.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Pakman Dotcom.
We will see you then or otherwise on Monday.